le message est clair pour le modem c'est
Jupé ou rien le parti centriste soutient
l'ancien Premier ministre pour la
primaire de la droite question de valeur
question d'idée ou encore d'amitié le
seul qui se soit déclaré ouvertement
pour un large
rassemblement ils appellent ça
progressiste mais pour ça un large
rassemblement humaniste porteur d'idées
nouvelles porteur de témoins vers une
politique autrement le seul qui les fait
c'est Alain Jupé et ça correspond
exactement à à tout ce qu'on prône
depuis 10 ans déjà donc c'est
naturellement qu'on va vers lui les
autres n'ont rien montré de tel donc
effectivement on va vers Alain Jupé et
en plus vous connaissez les liens
d'amitié qui le qui le lie à à François
Baayou d'amitié de respect et si le
maire de Bordeaux ne remporte pas la
primaire au mois de novembre le modem 78
menace et présente déjà une liste de
candidats pour les élections
législatives de l'an prochain avec 12
binôme qui défendront leur valeurs c'est
un risque mais si on ne le prend pas de
toute façon on n'existera jamais donc
quelque part vous avez vu que nous avons
une vision humaniste et nous voulons la
développer et c'est en en parlant en
agissant au quotidien que nous allons
vendre nos idées et que les gens vont
petit à petit y adhérer et moi j'y crois
et c'est pour ça que je m'engage parmi
les autres candidats préinvestis George
Bev sur la 10e circonscription la
primaire de la droite et du centre se
tiendra les 20 et 27 novembre prochain h
candidats sont en LCE et Alain Jupé
reste le favori selon les sages
impossible